so I'm Ian Grundy from the adecco group
in Switzerland based in Singapore in
Asia I think what's interesting in an
event like this is the need and the
focus on talent and job creation we're
hearing a lot at the very interesting
seminars here at the World Economic
Forum about the amazing growth that's
happening in Asia and how we support
that but what's overriding all of this
is the need for talent for every single
country and every economy to grow that's
going to need to be the right people
that's going to need to be training for
those people that's going to need to be
an element of education and also then a
high level of mobility where do those
people work and how do they work and I
think one of the big takeaways for me is
that reinforcement of the very important
role of human resources in every
organization and how those companies are
structured it's something that's going
to be really interesting as the Asian
economies grow over the next two five
and ten years